uh you tweeted
one of the underreported reasons
conspiracy theories take hold
is because some of them are true
what uh conspiracy theories do you
believe
that are sort of
important for people to think about
would you say um
kennedy was not killed by a lone gunman
with no connections to any other
situation government you know i believe
that jfk was removed from office
uh by a group of people that had
very uh different interests
but the question of like deep state so
these are powerful people
that are able now to dictate uh
through basically the threat of violence
what the
president's the surface powerful people
in our society yeah i mean i've no
again i'm not i i want another
investigation into 911 not because i
think
george bush pressed the button and made
911 happen but because we invaded the
country of iraq
and then we uh you know 15 out of 19
hijackers were from saudi arabia
uh there was tons of stuff in the 911
report that didn't make sense to anybody
uh there's tons of stuff about that day
that i feel like we just don't know
yeah that's hard to interrupt uh that's
when
i my little aunt life touched upon
conspiracy theory world and first
learned about alex jones
is when 9 11 happened it was very
frustrating to me
how poorly the reporting and the
transparency around what exactly
happened
who knew what all that kind of basic
information that you would hope
the government would release
reveal and use as like a lesson for how
we prevent this instead it felt like a
lot of stuff was being hidden
in order to manipulate some kind of
machine that leads us to war
yeah that's that's fair to say yeah i
mean i just don't feel like we've gotten
the full story i don't know what the
full story is right
i can't i don't know what it is but i
don't feel like we've gotten the full
story
um yeah there are there are groups of
powerful pedophiles
right whether they're in the catholic
church or they're in the government or
wherever they are they are able to cover
things up that they do they're able to
silence people that try to out them in
terms of like
you know disrupt their operations that's
true q anon has nuggets of truth
it just went crazy any conspiracy theory
that involves the knights templar and
also
chrissy teigen is probably wrong
right now what's the nice templar well
it was just this group of
knights back in the day you know it's
that you just supposedly secret meetings
and like in every conspiracy they talk
about like
you know if you go deep enough it's like
the ninth template there were secretions
uh you know all of these secret groups
throughout history the illuminati
the and there's a thread that connects
all of us oh yes it connects it all to
david spade i mean it's a little much
well how do you if you're david spade
defend yourself by the way you ignore it
because it's hilarious and i know
david's pay it's like
hollywood's kind of boring yes there are
sex orgies i'm not invited
i'm sure there's [ __ ] going on kids do
get abused women get abused
i'll invite you to one please if you
want with the we get we got the seventy
five thousand dollar dog
yeah and then we'll get one but you know
i
you know me david's baby we go out to
sushi restaurants like and you sit there
and you listen to people complain
that's what a lot of it is what a lot of
hollywood is is deeply sad
tragedy that people don't understand
that it's some of it is nefarious and
dark and there are problems and there
are
real power brokers here it's a dark town
but they think that everybody that lives
here is in some wide-ranging vast
conspiracy isn't true
it ignores how humdrum boring
deeply sad most people's lives are in
hollywood
and it ignores how sad fame is in
general
fame's a sad thing not always but a lot
of times
it's a sad thing it's fleeting it's
ephemeral it doesn't last
it um separates you from other people
it's isolating uh it can be traumatic
depending on what's going on
obviously it's better than the
alternative if you're trying to be
famous
it's better to be famous than not famous
right i'll say that
but it's it's it's a mixed bag to a
degree there are things about it that
aren't great
and hollywood has a deep undercurrent of
sadness of people that have
not realized their dreams and people
that have realized them
yeah both of those people like the
people that win olympic gold medals can
sometimes suffer from depression correct
they've lost well somebody said i forget
who said it it's a great quote it's not
mine i think it's from a book or it
might be from a tv show sometimes it
quotes something and they're like
that's from like charlotte's web i'm
like oh uh the two worst things
oh i think it's from the movie limitless
i'm like an idiot but anyway
thanks for having me on tomorrow i will
never
not publish this um it's for the movie
and i think he says uh the worst two
worst things in the world are knockout
oh
you know it's not from limitless i think
it's from the mat that the movie
where nicholas cage sold weapons it was
called lord of war
it's a little better than limitless
anyway it's a good movie it's a great
movie
he said the two worst things in the
world are not getting what you want and
getting it
so the undercurrents of sadness that run
through hollywood are there two rivers
that converge
and there are people that just never had
it and people that have it and go now
what
and so it's a sad place a tragic place
and there's a lot of it's boring
that's what people don't realize just
like it's actually kind of boring well
life is kind of boring life is kind of
boring but there's also like
you know so i think q anon's this way to
make a lot of it seem like it's super
exciting
and listen i don't want to diminish the
experiences of people who've been abused
because there is a lot of horror here
yeah but the whole q a thing was like
everybody in everything is doing and
that's not true
you